[Music]
I guess it's Jonah here take a wave
let's face it they are extremely
convenient for us busy people they're
cheap huge important and let's not
forget absolutely crappy for your body
and then you start wondering why am I
putting on weight why do I feel bloated
and lethargic all the time well maybe
it's due to the amount of takeaways
you've been eating by the time you wait
for your food to be delivered to your
doorstep
you could have trap in your own healthy
takeaways so I'm going to share with you
some of the most famous Chinese
takeaways which can be made healthy
nutritious and equally just as delicious
let's start with the famous garlic egg
fried rice so what you'll need are two
cups of cooked rice I used a mixture of
brown and also white right through
garlic clove minced about two green
onions roughly chopped two eggs
one and a half tablespoons of sesame oil
or any other oil of your choice and also
just a pinch of salt let's start by
beating the eggs and then put it to one
side then in a large pan heat oil over
medium-high heat and garlic and saute
very quickly until lightly browned
just for about one to two minutes then
add in the eggs and stir continuously
until it's properly scrambled then very
quickly
add in the cooked rice and also green
onions keep mixing until all the
ingredients are well blended and don't
forget to season with a little bit of
salt
that's hot so a Chinese takeaway is
never complete without everybody's
favorite sweet and sour chicken
the typical lipslide is better sweet and
sour chicken can sometime to rack up to
500 calories per serving and it is high
in saturated fat and oh so sodium my
version has just over 200 calories and
it is low in saturated fat and also
sodium so it is very possible to make a
healthier version without sacrificing
the taste what I've use are 12 ounces of
skinless chicken breast fillets sliced
into cute 1 medium red and green bell
pepper roughly
cut into chunks half a red onion roughly
chopped have a cup of pineapple cut into
chunks two garlic cloves minced one and
a half tablespoons of sesame oil a
handful of fresh cilantro roughly
chopped and just about quarter teaspoon
of red chili flakes or more if you like
spicy food as for the sweet and sour
sauce I used quarter cup of ketchup
quarter cup of rice vinegar about one
and a half tablespoons of raw honey
quarter cup of water and 1 tablespoon of
cornstarch mixed with two tablespoons of
cold water so let's start by marinating
the chicken with one egg white and about
1 teaspoon of light soy sauce and let
the chicken sit for about 15 minutes
then in a large pan heat oil over
medium-high heat stir in the marinated
chicken and saute for about 5 minutes
until chicken is almost cooked through
then stir in the garlic onion bell
peppers and cheese flakes continue to
saute until all ingredients are mixed
well we want to keep them crunchy okay
so don't overcook them then stir in the
pineapple and sweet and sour sauce
mixture continue to cook very quickly
for another two to three minutes until
all the ingredients are evenly coated
and removed from heat
finally just sprinkle with a little bit
of cilantro and sir
Chinese people enjoy a generous serving
of vegetables my favorite has to be the
Buddha's delight which is essentially
just mixed vegetables so you can choose
and mix any vegetables of your choice
for my recipe I used a head of broccoli
cut into florets one carrot thinly
sliced about half a cup of shiitake
mushrooms thinly sliced 1 cup of snow
peas 3 garlic cloves minced point
tablespoon of light soy sauce 1
tablespoon of sesame oil and just a
pinch of salt again in a pan we want to
heat oil over medium-high heat then stir
in the garlic and salt it very quickly
just for about 1 to 2 minutes until
slightly Brown then stir in all the
vegetables and cook until vegetables are
tender if you need to you can add a
little bit of water finally mix in the
soy sauce and season with a little bit
of salt this dish should make up the
largest portion of your meal so feel
free to consume in abundance my version
of Chinese takeaway has a good balance
of vegetables protein and complex cast
and the entire meal has just over 500
calories and it is extremely satisfying
so I like to cook them in bulk and bring
a portion out with me to work and also
spray to the extras in the fridge so
when I'm back from work feeling really
tired and lazy I know I have a healthy
Chinese takeaway from me in the fridge
so guys be sure to try these recipes out
and share your creation with me on
Facebook and Instagram Tek me as a
journalist or official and hashtagged
adjacent recipes if you enjoy this video
be sure to like it share with a friend
and subscribe to my youtube channel for
a lot more healthy recipes and also
Fitness content all the best